Un étrange bestiaire d'insectes
géants régnait sur la terre,
il y a 300 millions d'années.
Au fil du temps, ces créatures
étonnantes ont rétréci ou disparu.
Pourquoi ?
Une enquête paléontologique lève
aujourd'hui le voile sur la disparition,
de ces libellules de l'envergure d'un faucon.
Et ces mille-pattes plus grand qu'un homme.
Il y a 358 millions d'années, des continents
se rassemblent pour former la Pangée.
C'est le début d'une période
nommée Carbonifère,
durant laquelle le taux d'oxygène,
monte jusqu'à 35% contre 21 aujourd'hui.
Des arbres géants stockent
du dioxyde de carbone,
et relâchent de l'oxygène en abondance.
L'organisme humain ne serait pas
adapté à une telle quantité d'oxygène.
Pourtant, elle convient parfaitement
à quelques monstres des marais.
Arthropleura, pouvant mesurer jusqu'à
2m60,
un cousin des mille-pattes.
Meganeura, avec son envergure de 70 cm,
cet insecte de la famille des libellules
n'a aucun concurrent dans le ciel.
Les oiseaux et les reptiles volants
ne sont pas encore apparus.
La reine des airs, c'est elle.
Cette couleur sépia propre au
ciel du Carbonifère,
tient à leur concentration
élevée en oxygène.
Un gaz qui rend l'air extrêmement
sensible au départ d'incendie.
Ce monde est aussi hostile qu'inimaginable.
Le moindre orage, le moindre éclair risque
d'enflammer ses immenses forêts,
et ses habitants.
Pourtant, ces feux de forêts gigantesques,
courant ou Carbonifère,
n'ont pas empêché les insectes géants
de vivre à cette époque.
C'est quand les incendies se sont raréfiés
que ces étonnantes créatures ont disparu.
Les scientifiques cherchent à savoir
qui est responsable de leur extinction.
Il y a plusieurs coupables en fait, comme
dans tous les bons romans d'Agatha Christie,
Où il n'y a pas qu'un meurtrier
mais plusieurs meurtriers,
et c'est à nous de reconstituer
avec les éléments qu'on a,
toutes les enquêtes pour essayer d'avoir
le scénario le plus fiable possible.
La modification de l'atmosphère fut longtemps
la seule explication de leur disparition.
Mais depuis la fin des années 2000, la
découverte de somptueux fossiles d'insectes,
et de leurs prédateurs,
ouvre de nouvelles pistes d'analyse.
C'est une hypothèse merveilleuse.
Les insectes géants avaient
certainement des prédateurs,
mais nous n'en avons pas la preuve.
Partout dans le monde,
Les scientifiques confrontent les théories
anciennes aux fossiles récemment découverts,
pour expliquer enfin,
grâce à des expériences novatrices,
pourquoi ces géants se sont éteints.
Les tout premiers fossiles
d'insectes géants,
ont été trouvés en 1880,
en France, dans l'Allier.
Conservés depuis 300 millions d'années,
sous la surface de cet étang.
Ces Meganeuras seraient les plus gros
insectes volants ayant vécu sur terre.
C'est en exploitant ce gisement désaffecté
que les fossiles ont été découverts,
tout près du village de Commentry.
Le propriétaire de la mine, Monsieur Monyi,
a donné son nom au spécimen conservé
au Muséum d'histoire naturelle de Paris,
Meganeura Monyi.
André Nel, paléontologue expert
des premiers insectes,
Veille sur cette précieuse pièce.
Les mineurs cherchaient les fossiles
pour améliorer leurs fins de mois.
Et un jour, ils sont tombés, en ouvrant
des dalles, sur cet animal là.
Malheureusement, en le découvrant, ils lui
ont donné quatre coups de pioche, mal placés.
Donc on a perdu la tête de l'animal.
C'était le super prédateur de l'époque,
prédateur d'autres insectes,
qui eux aussi était de grande taille.
Les grands fossiles restent exceptionnels.
Des milliers d'insectes
ont été exhumés à Commentry,
contre seulement cinq Meganeura.
Le Meganeura avait 4 ailes, de chaque côté,
attachées au thorax, au centre,
devant, on avait une tête avec de gros yeux
parce que c'était un prédateur,
les yeux lui servaient à voir,
comme chez les libellules modernes,
son environnement à 360 degrés,
donc éventuellement en arrière même.
Pour continuer à faire le portrait
de cet insecte disparu,
nous devons remonter le temps
300 millions d'années en arrière.
A l'époque carbonifère,
le département français de l'Allier
est un marécage géant.
constellé de cyprès chauves.
Chargé en oxygène mais aussi en humidité,
l'atmosphère est extrêmement dense,
ce qui permet à Meganeura de transporter
avec aisance sa lourde carapace.
Elle fait partie d'un genre
aujourd'hui éteint,
mais ressemble aux libellules
à laquelle elle est reliée,
dans le même super ordre des Odonatopteras.
C'est en comparant l'anatomie de Meganeura
avec celle des libellules actuelles,
que les scientifiques peuvent
imaginer sa physiologie,
grâce à ses ailes indépendantes,
elle devait être relativement agile en vol.
Face à ce terrible prédateur,
les insectes végétariens
comme le Paléodictyoptère,
ne pouvaient compter que sur leur discrétion.
Meganeura devait faire des pointes à 70 km/h
et même s'élever à plus de 5 mètres par seconde.
Elle chasse à vue.
Comme sa tête est indépendante
du reste du corps,
elle la garde fixe en vol,
pour mieux atteindre ses proies.
Vu sa corpulence, Meganeura
devait avoir un appétit gargantuesque.
Que ses mandibules acérées et ses pattes
tranchantes révélées par les fossiles,
permettent de rassasier.
A l'écart du public,
dans la réserve du Muséum
sont conservés des spécimens rares.
Des Meganeuras.
Mais aussi leur proie herbivores
presque aussi impressionnante.
Peut être le signe
d'une course au gigantisme.
Donc là, vous avez un exemple d'une Meganeura,
sur laquelle on voit
les départs des ailes, le thorax,
mais surtout, ce qui est assez
spectaculaire, ce sont les quatre pattes,
garnies de fortes épines,
qui servaient justement à poignarder la proie.
Les proies de ces Meganeura, c'était
des insectes de très grande taille aussi,
comme ce Paléodictyoptère.
Ce sont de grands insectes,
là, vous avez uniquement une aile
qui va de là à là.
Donc vous imaginez la bête complète.
C'étaient les proies de ces Meganeura,
grande taille aussi,
donc insecte de grande taille pour échapper
à un prédateur de grande taille.
On a affaire effectivement à une course aux
armements entre prédateurs et proies.
Les fossiles des insectes végétariens
ne révèlent aucune défense.
Croître était leur seule chance de survie.
Mais cette bataille des géants
semble avoir atteint une limite.
Sinon, les paléontologues auraient trouvé des
fossiles d'insectes plus grands et terrifiants encore.
La quête de nourriture occupait sans doute
le plus clair de la journée des Meganeuras,
au métabolisme très énergivore.
Selon les scientifiques,
le gigantisme des insectes du Carbonifère,
tiendrait à la forte concentration
en oxygène de l'air ambiant.
Les insectes ne respirent
pas par des poumons,
mais par un système unique de tubes.
Les trachées et trachéole,
qui apportent directement
l'air aux organes vitaux.
Cette respiration passive
n'est pas très performante.
L'air est conduit dans les tissus
sous forme gazeuse.
Et plus un insecte est grand,
plus il a besoin d'oxygène.
C'est effectivement bizarre que ces animaux
atteignent cette taille là,
parce qu'actuellement on n'a pas
d'insectes aussi grands.
Et à l'époque des dinosaures, alors
qu'on avait de très gros vertébrés,
les insectes étaient beaucoup plus petits.
Il se trouve qu'au Carbonifère, on pense,
pour des raisons de géochimie,
que le taux d'oxygène dans l'atmosphère
était plus élevé qu'actuellement.
Donc ça aurait favorisé le développement
d'animaux de type insecte de grande taille.
Les Meganeuras ne pourraient pas survivre
dans l'atmosphère actuelle.
L'oxygène n'atteindrait pas en assez grande quantité
leurs organes, notamment le cerveau,
et elles tomberaient en syncope.
Alors que les scientifiques émettent
depuis le début du XXᵉ siècle,
cette hypothèse d'un lien entre taille
des insectes et concentration en oxygène.
Une expérience étonnante vient enfin
le prouver en 2007 seulement.
Elle s'est déroulée dans un lieu à la pointe
de la technologie aux États-Unis,
dans la banlieue de Chicago.
C'est là que se trouve le plus puissant
synchrotron américain.
Un scanner générateur de rayons X situé
au sein du laboratoire Argonne.
Et si Jake Socha, le scientifique
en charge de l'étude,
parcourt les couloirs à vélo,
C'est parce que le périmètre de cet
accélérateur de particules,
fait plus d'un kilomètre.
Aujourd'hui, ce sont des insectes
vivants qui vont passer au scanner.
Notre principe, c'est d'utiliser des insectes
actuels pour mieux comprendre,
ceux qui ont vécu dans le passé.
Nous avons essayé de tester
une vieille hypothèse,
selon laquelle le niveau
d'oxygène dans l'atmosphère,
limite la taille des insectes.
L'idée, c'est que plus il a d'oxygène, plus
les insectes sont grands,
et moins il y a d'oxygène,
plus les insectes sont petits.
Mais personne n'avait encore réellement
testé cette hypothèse.
Nous avons donc utilisé les rayons X du synchrotron
pour scruter l'intérieur des insectes,
et étudier la taille
de leur système respiratoire.
Cet accélérateur de particules produit des
rayons X extrêmement intenses et focalisés,
qui traversent le corps de l'insecte.
Notre but est d'observer
le système respiratoire en mouvement.
Dans certains cas, les tubes
respiratoires sont vraiment petits.
Comme nous voulons les observer
sur des animaux vivants,
c'est vraiment la seule technologie
qui nous permette de voir tout cela.
Grâce à cette expérience, pour la première fois,
des scientifiques peuvent enfin
observer un insecte respirer.
Ils réalisent que les criquets utilisent tout
leur corps pour faire parvenir l'air aux organes,
comme le montrent les images rayons X.
Vous pouvez voir cette bulle dans le système
digestif qui avance vers la tête de l'animal,
puis recule.
À chaque fois, elle est synchronisée
avec la compression du système respiratoire.
Ces mouvements que l'on voit
à l'écran ne sont pas passifs.
C'est un mouvement actif de l'animal
provoqué principalement,
par la compression des muscles.
Ce criquet utilise les contractions
de son tube digestif pour respirer.
Comme l'abdomen de Meganeura
devait se contracter,
pour absorber l'air épais du Carbonifère.
Sa carapace de chitine élastique
reprenait sa forme,
une fois l'action des muscles terminée.
Jake Socha étudie aussi la place occupée,
par le système respiratoire
dans l'organisme des insectes.
Sujet de cette expérience,
des scarabées de différentes tailles.
Ce que nous avons découvert,
c'est que la trachée,
occupe une part bien plus grande du corps
que l'on pourrait imaginer,
quand la taille de l'insecte augmente.
Ce que nous pensons
après avoir mené cette étude,
c'est que si l'animal grossissait de plus en plus,
on atteindrait une limite au delà de laquelle,
le système respiratoire ne pourrait pas
occuper tout l'espace dans son corps.
Car il doit y avoir aussi d'autres organes.
Comme des muscles, des intestins,
des tissus nerveux, de la graisse,
tout ce qui est important
pour la physiologie de l'animal.
Il est impossible d'avoir
juste un énorme système respiratoire.
Quand le taux d'oxygène a baissé,
les insectes géants se seraient fait plus petit,
au fil des millions d'années.
Et tous n'auraient pas été
aussi résistants au changement.
Il y a 290 millions d'années, au
cours d'une époque baptisée le Permien,
le taux d'oxygène baisse de 35 à 23%.
Un taux proche de celui d'aujourd'hui.
La Pangée forme déjà un supercontinent.
Étendue d'un pôle à l'autre,
elle est soumise à des conditions
climatiques extrêmes.
Au cœur des continents,
des déserts apparaissent,
tandis qu'à l'équateur subsistent
les grandes forêts humides du Carbonifère.
Durant cette période de changement
climatique rythmé par les moussons,
un champignon vivant sur
l'écorce des arbres apparaît.
Cette pourriture blanche dégrade la cellulose
du bois grâce à une enzyme spécifique.
Progressivement, les débris végétaux
et les arbres morts sont décomposés.
Ils ne s'amoncellent plus
comme avant pour former du charbon.
Le carbone est recyclé dans l'atmosphère
et la proportion d'oxygène chute progressivement.
Ce qui a des conséquences sur l'environnement.
Cette période charnière va voir
disparaître les arthtopleura,
ces cousins des mille-pattes.
Mais pourquoi furent-ils
les premiers géants à disparaître ?
Les terrils qui cernent
la ville française d'Autun,
sont la marque de son passé industriel.
Au Musée d'histoire naturelle,
hommage est rendu aux mineurs
qui ont découvert en 1977,
les fossiles d'Arthropleura.
Notamment cette trace
la plus imposante trouvée en France.
Elle est scrutée par Sylvain Charbonnier,
un spécialiste des arthropodes,
cette famille d'espèces qui comprend les insectes,
mais aussi ses ancêtres des mille-pattes.
Là, on a une piste,
vous avez deux sillons parallèles.
Ça fait déjà un organisme de taille
respectable,
donc une bête qui devait
faire presque 1 mètre.
C'est juste un fragment de la piste qui
devait être sans doute beaucoup plus importante.
Aucun fossile de taille adulte
n'a jamais été découvert,
mais les paléontologues ont trouvé
de nombreux jeunes Arthropleuras,
dans ces concrétions de charbon.
Alors vous avez ici à quoi
ressemblait cette bête.
Là ce sont des spécimens juvéniles,
donc ils sont tout petits.
C'est le spécimen complet avec
sa carapace qui est bien préservée.
Cet organisme en grandissant,
va pouvoir donner des traces beaucoup plus
larges lorsqu'il va se déplacer.
L'Arthopleura ressemblait
à un mille-pattes actuel,
mais il n'a plus d'équivalent dans la nature.
Cet animal pouvait atteindre 3 mètres,
et ramper au sol ou dans les arbres
à la recherche de nourriture.
Au début du Permien,
il y a 290 millions d'années.
La vie dans les forêts équatoriales n'est pas
très différente de celle du Carbonifère.
L'Arthropleura, trouve encore
assez d'oxygène pour affronter,
d'autres animaux de grande taille.
Comme un Eryops.
Cet amphibien l'a repéré grâce aux cellules
de sa peau qui lui permettent,
de détecter les vibrations du tronc.
L'Arthropleura à l'avantage
d'une centaine de pattes articulées,
dont les griffes agrippent bien l'écorce.
Et surtout une carapace
qui le protège des agresseurs.
Arthropleura ne craint pas les prédateurs.
Ce qui aurait causé sa perte,
c'est l'assèchement de la forêt.
Car cette créature était herbivore.
Ces somptueuse plantes fossilisés
faisaient son régal.
La végétation à cette époque,
c'est une végétation de type
équatorial ou tropical,
donc une végétation très luxuriante
avec énormément de plantes.
Ces plantes seront d'ailleurs
à l'origine du charbon.
Arthopleura vivait dans
cet environnement forestier.
Vous avez également en face des troncs
d'arbre dont les feuilles,
ont été également retrouvées dans
le contenu stomacal d'Arthropleura.
Donc ils devaient se nourrir
de branches de ces arbres.
Est-ce qu'il les prélevait
sur des arbres qui étaient couchés,
ou est-ce qu'il grimpait
un petit peu dans l'arbre ?
Ce sont des hypothèses,
on le saura probablement jamais.
La sève semble presque couler dans ces
plantes scellées dans la roche,
depuis 320 millions d'années.
Arthropleura n'aurait pas
survécu à leur raréfaction.
Cet environnement forestier,
à la fin du Carbonifère,
va avoir tendance à s'assécher.
Le climat va changer,
la végétation va disparaître,
et Arthropleura va perdre
sa source de nourriture.
Et c'est probablement une des raisons
pour laquelle il va aussi disparaître.
En 10 millions d'années,
l'atmosphère et le climat
se modifient rapidement,
sonnant le glas des Arthropleuras
dont les derniers fossiles datent,
d'il y a 280 millions d'années.
Mais tous les insectes géants
n'ont pas disparu au même rythme.
En 2009, la découverte de Meganeura
fossilisé plus tardivement,
il y a 250 millions d'années,
créé l'étonnement.
Quels indices ces fossiles inattendus
exhumés dans le sud de la France,
révèlent-ils aux scientifiques ?
Ce somptueux paysage rythmé par les roches
rouges du massif des Maures,
se trouve en Provence.
Les gisements datant du Permien
sont très rares.
On en connaît qu'une quinzaine dans le monde
et tous n'ont pas été entièrement fouillés,
comme c'est le cas ici.
Sur l'un des sites explorés
actuellement par André Nel.
Ici, nous sommes à 250 millions d'années dans
le Permien rouge continental.
Permien rouge parce que les roches
se sont oxydées,
le fer oxydé a donné cette couleur rouge.
Donc on a affaire à un milieu extrêmement
riche en organisme,
qui ont laissé leur empreinte mais qui
ont laissé peu de fossiles visibles pour l'instant.
En tout cas pour ce gisement là.
Mais heureusement, d'autres gisements
ont livré les fossiles en question.
C'est dans une couche géologique identique,
que des fossiles d'insectes ont été
découverts en 2009 près de Montpellier.
Pendant très longtemps, on a pensé que ces
libellules géantes existaient au Carbonifère,
et au début du Permien, mais qu'elle n'existait
plus vers le milieu et la fin du Permien,
on a eu la surprise de découvrir encore des libellules
aussi grandes que celles du Carbonifère.
Les paléontologues sont surpris parce qu'à
cette époque, le taux d'oxygène avait déjà baissé.
Il ne devrait plus y avoir
de fossiles d'insectes géants.
Ces spécimens variés conservés dans le
laboratoire parisien d'André Nel,
prouvent le contraire.
Il y a des toutes petites
ailes de Meganeuridae, comme celle-ci.
De cette taille là.
C'est une taille d'ailes de libellule moderne,
c'est la même chose.
On a des espèces beaucoup plus grandes.
Si vous avez une aile postérieure,
d'un autre Meganeuridae,  d'une autre espèce,
là c'était encore un géant.
On a même encore plus grand,
mais fragmentaire,
cette chose là est morceaux d'une aile de Meganeuridae,
dont la taille était comparable à celle
de Meganeura du Carbonifère.
Donc on a estimé à 60 cm d'envergure.
On s'aperçoit qu'avec ces animaux là, on a
une grande diversité,
c'est même à ce moment là qu'ils
sont le plus diversifié.
On en a des tout petits, des moyens,
des plus grands, des très grands.
Ça veut dire qu'ils n'étaient vraiment pas
en état d'extinction à ce moment là.
Ça ne colle pas au scénario d'une extinction
dû à la baisse du taux d'oxygène.
Ces meganeuras,
parmi les plus récentes connues,
ont été découvertes dans le sud de la France,
mais aussi aux Etats-Unis.
Leur existence n'est donc pas une exception.
Il y a 270 millions d'années,
la terre est chaude et humide.
Avec un taux d'oxygène à peine
supérieur à celui d'aujourd'hui.
L'air nous paraîtrait
parfaitement respirable.
Pourtant, un genre animal continue
d'exister contre toute attente.
Les Meganeuras représentés
par cette Meganeuropsis.
Ce spécimen découvert au Texas est aussi
grand que ses cousines françaises.
Mais comment cet insecte volant de 50 cm
de long pouvait-il survivre à l'époque ?
Posséderait-il un atout qui faisait
défaut aux Arthropleuras ?
Le fossile de Meganeuropsis
a été découvert en 1937,
près de Kansas City, aux États-Unis.
Non loin du campus universitaire
où travaille Michael Engels,
ce paléontologue auteur d'une Bible
sur l'évolution des insectes,
est le directeur d'une impressionnante
collection de 4,7 millions de spécimens.
Pour la majorité,
des insectes vivant dans le monde actuel.
Voici certains des plus grands
insectes vivants aujourd'hui.
Des grands papillons de nuit,
des phasmes, des coléoptères,
des libellules, des demoiselles.
Leur taille peut paraître impressionnante,
mais elle reste pourtant modeste
comparé aux insectes du passé.
Selon Michael Engels, l'arme clé des Meganeuras,
pour survivre dans une atmosphère moins riche
en oxygène serait leurs ailes.
Un insecte volant pourrait plus facilement
atteindre une grande taille,
qu'un insecte qui ne vole pas.
Les ailes sont vitales pour le mouvement
de l'organisme, mais pas seulement.
quand les muscles se contractent pour faire
bouger les ailes de haut en bas,
ils exercent une pression sur les alvéoles,
favorisant le déplacement
de l'air dans l'organisme.
Voler donne un avantage aux insectes géant,
car le mouvement des ailes augmente
leur métabolisme,
en oxygénant leurs tissus actifs.
Ce qui n'est pas le cas pour les insectes
non volants ou les arthropodes.
Le secret de leur survie serait la ventilation.
Les ailes envoient l'air plus rapidement vers
les trachées pour mieux oxygéner tous les organes.
Alors que les géants du Carbonifère
vivant au sol ont disparu,
Meganeuropsis continue de régner dans le ciel
tout en haut de la chaîne alimentaire.
Ce Diplocaulus,
un amphibien aujourd'hui disparu,
n'avait aucune chance de passer inaperçu
car ses besoins en air le trahissent,
dès qu'il quitte le couvert de l'eau.
Meganeuropsis dont les yeux sont extrêmement
sensibles aux mouvements,
aux formes et aux couleurs, le repère.
Prédateur aérien hors pair.
Meganeuropsis a survécu malgré
la baisse du taux d'oxygène.
Le mystère des causes de son extinction
est donc relancé.
Pour le moment, les scientifiques ne savent
pas exactement,
quand les Meganeuras ont disparu.
Mais d'autres libellules de grande taille
leur ont survécu pendant 130 millions d'années.
Pour expliquer l'extinction totale
des insectes géants,
Les scientifiques se tourne donc vers
l'apparition de nouveaux prédateurs.
Car si les insectes furent longtemps
les seuls à voler,
il y a 250 millions d'années,
d'autres animaux les ont
concurrencés dans les airs.
Jean Sébastien Steyer, paléontologue au
Muséum d'histoire naturelle de Paris,
est le spécialiste français des reptiles volant.
Dans la mythique galerie de paléontologie,
il vient chercher un spécimen primordial
pour l'étude des prédateurs des insectes.
Plus petits que bien d'autres fossiles,
cet animal découvert en Allemagne
est le premier de son espèce à voler.
Alors ce fossile correspond
à un reptile planeur,
qui a environ 250 millions d'années,
et qui porte le nom barbare
de Coelurosauravus.
C'est un reptile qui avait développé
le vol plané.
C'est pour capturer les insectes en vol que
ce reptile insectivore,
se lance dans les airs.
Il y a 250 millions d'années,
le réchauffement s'accentue.
Les marécages, des sources
inépuisables de fossiles,
se pare de plantes aquatiques
propres aux eaux stagnantes.
Apparu comme les insectes au Carbonifère,
les reptiles s'essaient tout juste
à la vie dans les arbres et au vol.
Parmi eux, le Coelurosauravus va se
spécialiser dans la chasse aux insectes,
grâce à ses dents pointues
et ses ailes escamotables.
Il avait une anatomie tout à fait
particulière et intéressante.
Il a une tête assez fine en triangle.
Au niveau du crâne, on observe des petites
dents coniques et pointues,
qui perçaient sans doute les carapaces
assez robustes des insectes de l'époque.
Et puis la caractéristique principale
bien sûr de ce reptile planeur,
ce sont les baguettes osseuses
qui partent au niveau des aisselles,
et qui permettaient à cet animal de s'élancer
dans les airs et de faire du base jump.
On peut l'imaginer escalader par exemple
ce microscope et puis sauter.
On peut même l'imaginer escalader
avec ces petites griffes et puis,
développer ses ailes et planer.
On peut imaginer des course poursuite,
entre Coelurosauravus
et les insectes volants de l'époque.
Avec ces petits 40 centimètres de long,
Coelurosauravus ne pouvait pas
s'attaquer au Meganeura,
mais il convoite les mêmes proies qu'elles.
Comme ce Paléodictyoptère.
Pour espérer l'attraper,
il doit faire le grand saut.
Coelurosauravus ne peut pas battre des ailes.
Pour capturer des insectes volants,
il compte sur l'effet de surprise.
Et sa maîtrise du vol plané.
Toute approximation est sévèrement punie.
Le Coelurosauravus
n'est qu'un premier brouillon,
une première esquisse du vol,
mais les reptiles auront bientôt leur revanche.
Ce reptile planeur a sans doute
joué un rôle effectivement,
peut-être pas dans l'extinction
totale des insectes géants,
mais en tout cas, on a là un super prédateur,
qui les attaque régulièrement et donc on peut
penser que cet élément là,
a participé à la diminution en nombre
des insectes aux géants de l'époque.
S'il n'est pas le seul coupable,
Coelurosauravus aurait été le premier
à concurrencer les insectes géants,
avant que d'autres espèces n'envahissent
les airs à leur tour.
Cet animal qui garde l'entrée
du musée de Karlsruhe en Allemagne,
fait partie de la famille des ptérosaures,
apparus il y a 230 millions d'années,
ce sont eux aussi des reptiles volants.
Ils sont aujourd'hui totalement éteints,
mais les scientifiques en ont découvert
une centaine d'espèces différentes.
Pouvaient-ils constituer une menace
pour les insectes de grande taille ?
Le professeur Eberhard Frey,
connu sous le nom de Dino,
est le spécialiste mondial
de ces animaux étonnants.
Les ptérosaures sont des reptiles volants
caractérisés par une membrane à l'air,
qui s'étend de la pointe de leur petit doigt
jusqu'à leurs chevilles.
Ce qui est intéressant chez les ptérosaures,
c'est que la variété de taille
est tout simplement incroyable.
Elle va de 20 centimètres
jusqu'à 14 mètres d'envergure,
ce qui est unique.
Selon les scientifiques,
rares sont les ptérosaures
à manger des insectes.
Les seuls à posséder des dents adaptés seraient
ceux de la famille d'Anurognathus.
Parmi les plus petits des ptérosaures.
Il est difficile d'imaginer qu'ils chassaient
vraiment des gros insectes,
mais probablement chassaient-ils les petits,
ceux qui ne sont pas représentés
parmi les fossiles.
Les gros insectes chassaient
aussi les petits insectes,
donc ils étaient certainement en concurrence
pour les mêmes proies.
Les autres ptérosaures de l'époque
se nourrissaient sans doute d'autre chose,
et ne faisaient donc pas
de concurrence aux gros insectes.
Et c'est peut être pour cela que les gros
insectes ont survécu aussi longtemps.
Au cours d'une époque nommée le Trias,
il y a 230 millions d'années,
les ptérosaures se répandent en Europe,
mais aussi en Amérique du Sud et en Asie.
Pour la première fois dans l'histoire
de la vie sur terre,
une famille de vertébrés apprend
à maîtriser le vol battu,
et pas seulement plané.
Comme Anurognathus découvert en Allemagne,
son cousin asiatique nommé Batrachognathus,
est un reptile volant, nocturne,
insectivore,
et agile.
Avec son crâne aplati et de grands yeux,
Le Batrachognathus occupe la niche
écologique des chouettes actuelles.
Mais la comparaison avec
les rapaces s'arrête là.
La mâchoire démesurée de cette gargouille vivante
est garnie d'une dizaine de dents coniques.
Aucun insecte volant ne semble à
l'abri de battre Anurognathus volant.
L'insecte Kaligrama, avec son envergure
atteignant 24 centimètres,
peut-il rivaliser ?
Une expérience réalisée en Allemagne
tente de répondre à cette question.
Dino Frey collabore avec l'Institut de
mécanique des fluides de Karlsruhe,
destiné à perfectionner
l'aérodynamique des avions,
cette soufflerie teste aussi
les capacités de vol des ptérosaures.
Un modèle d'Anurognathus
est placé face au tunnel.
Nous sommes au début de nos recherches, mais
ce que nous avons appris pour le moment,
c'est que les ptérosaures volaient
sans doute assez lentement.
Avec le vent, ils pouvaient atteindre
au maximum 40 km/h.
Ces espèces devaient probablement battre
des ailes pour rester dans les airs,
et n'étaient pas d'excellents planeurs.
Battre des ailes signifie aussi
qu'ils étaient actifs en vol,
et pouvaient donc manœuvrer plus facilement.
Ce qui est intéressant pour commencer
à chasser les insectes en vol.
Avec l'apparition des ptérosaures,
les insectes auraient
perdu le monopole du vol battu.
Batrachognathus s'éloigne ainsi du
rivage et poursuit les insectes à découvert.
Une distance impossible
à parcourir pour son ancêtre,
le lézard volant Coelurosauravus.
Dévorés par certains ptérosaures,
les proies des insectes géants
seraient moins disponibles.
Voilà une nouvelle cause de leur déclin.
Mais ce n'est pas la seule.
De l'autre côté de l'Atlantique,
aux Etats-Unis,
un chercheur désigne d'autres coupables
dans son étude publiée en août 2012.
Ce paléontologue est un spécialiste
des extinctions.
Plus technophile qu'homme de terrain,
c'est un féru de bases de données.
Son enquête sur la fin des insectes géants a
nécessité un an et demi de collecte d'informations.
Un travail de titan pour comparer la taille
de toutes les ailes fossiles exhumées,
depuis l'origine de la paléontologie.
Nous avons compilé cette importante base de
données de près de 10 000 espèces d'insectes,
simplement en reprenant les articles,
dans lesquels les paléontologues avaient
trouvé des fossiles d'insectes,
les avait décrit
et leur avait donné un nom.
Pendant la première partie
de l'histoire des insectes,
leur taille évolue en même temps
que le taux d'oxygène de l'atmosphère.
Ils rapetissent quand la concentration baisse
et grandissent quand elle augmente.
Ce schéma est valable pour les premiers
200 millions d'années de l'histoire des insectes.
Mais vers la fin du Jurassique,
il y a environ 150 millions d'années,
on voit que les insectes diminuent en taille,
même si le taux d'oxygène
est élevé à cette période.
Et cela coïncide assez bien
avec l'apparition des premiers oiseaux,
comme Archæoptéryx.
Les ancêtres des oiseaux apparaissent
à l'époque jurassique,
il y a 160 millions d'années.
Les fossiles les plus anciens
sont découverts en Chine.
Des forêts de gigantesques conifères offrent
de formidables tremplins pour conquérir le ciel.
Une niche écologique vite saisie par une
nouvelle génération de créatures,
qui s'essaye au vol.
De petits dinosaures comme cette Anchiornis,
portent des plumes sur
les pattes avant et arrière,
et s'en servent comme des ailes.
Les griffes au bout de leurs membres
permettent de prendre de l'altitude,
et d'atteindre des points panoramiques.
Les insectes doivent se camoufler
dans les arbres pour survivre.
En décollant, il devient visible
et Anchiornis le prend en chasse.
Alors que quelques ptérosaures
comme Anurognathus étaient insectivores,
c'est le cas de tous les ancêtres des oiseaux.
De plus en plus habiles en vol,
ils vont devenir de féroces
prédateurs pour les insectes.
Pendant le Crétacé lorsque
les premiers oiseaux apparaissent,
cette prédation sur les gros
insectes aurait augmenté.
D'autant qu'ils étaient moins
mobiles que les petits insectes.
En plus de cette prédation plus forte,
il y avait une concurrence entre
les oiseaux et les insectes.
En particulier les gros insectes pour
l'accès aux mêmes sources de nourriture.
Donc, ces deux facteurs sont susceptibles
d'avoir contribué,
à la diminution de la taille des insectes.
Cette course poursuite entre un ancêtre
des oiseaux et un insecte,
ressemble à celle qui
se déroule encore aujourd'hui.
Comme les lézards volants et les ptérosaures,
les oiseaux auraient exercé une pression
sur la taille des insectes.
Mais pourquoi les insectes géants
ont-ils totalement disparu,
pour laisser place au petit peuple d'aujourd'hui ?
Un dernier indice fossile
apporte une réponse inattendue.
C'est dans un gisement proche de celui
d'Anchiornis, le dinosaure à plumes,
qu'il a été trouvé.
En Chine, au Nord-Est de Pékin,
dans le Liaoning,
les éruptions volcaniques survenues
au Crétacé il y a 125 millions d'années,
ont emprisonné
dans les cendres certains végétaux,
et notamment les ancêtres des plantes à fleurs.
Découvertes en 2002 par le paléobotaniste Sun.
Ici en Chine, dans l'ouest du Liaoning,
nous avons trouvé le plus vieil angiospermes connu,
que nous avons nommé Archaefructus.
Voici la première fleur connue
qu'ait porté notre planète.
Sur ce fossile vu au microscope,
on distingue bien les organes mâles,
les étamines qui contiennent le pollen,
et l'organe femelle, le pistil.
Deux traits prouvant que ce fossile
appartient à la famille des angiospermes,
les végétaux dont les graines sont enfermées
à l'intérieur d'un fruit,
contrairement aux conifères.
Selon le paléobotaniste,
ces plantes étaient aquatiques
et poussaient au bord des lacs.
Mais quel est le lien entre
l'apparition des plantes à fleurs,
et la disparition des insectes carnivores
de grande taille ?
Pour André Nel, le paléontologue français
expert des insectes,
les deux événements seraient liés.
Énormément de familles d'insectes se sont
éteintes à ce moment là,
et d'autres qui ont réussi à s'adapter
aux angiospermes et qui là ont explosé,
se sont mis à se diversifier
pour donner les fonds modernes.
Et chez les libellules,
l'impact a été aussi significatif au même moment.
La clé de la fin des insectes géants se
trouverait dans la forme première des libellules.
Car avant de voler,
ce sont des créatures aquatiques.
Le tout début de leur vie se déroule sous l'eau.
Elles existent à l'état de larve
pendant plusieurs années.
Et comme leurs cousines,
les éphémères,
se nourrissent d'autres larves
d'insectes aquatiques.
Lorsque les plantes à fleurs comme Archaefructus
apparaissent sur la berge des lacs,
il y a 125 millions d'années,
les conditions de vie des larves changent.
Lorsque les pétales fanées sombrent dans l'eau,
les micro-organismes aquatiques se chargent
de les dégrader en dégageant du CO2.
Il consomme ainsi l'oxygène qui n'est plus
accessible aux larves des libellules.
Il est possible que ces libellules,
aient disparu à ce moment là parce que
leurs larves n'ont pas pu s'adapter,
à ce changement d'écosystèmes aquatiques,
et donc ont été remplacées
par d'autres libellules.
L'apparition des plantes à fleurs aurait
totalement modifié l'écosystème des lacs,
et mené à l'extinction des dernières
lignées d'insectes de grande taille.
La disparition des insectes géants
au fil de l'évolution est riche d'enseignements.
Ce n'est pas un, mais plusieurs
facteurs qui en sont responsables.
Modification de la composition
de l'atmosphère,
apparition de nouveaux prédateurs
comme les lézards volants,
certains ptérosaures
et les ancêtres des oiseaux,
et enfin la naissance des fleurs.
Aujourd'hui, en ce début de XXIᵉ siècle,
il subsiste seulement quelques
insectes de grande taille,
comme ce criquet chinois.
D'autant que nous sommes à l'aube
d'une nouvelle phase d'extinction,
provoqué par l'homme depuis le début
de la révolution industrielle.
Les insectes de grande taille vivent la plupart
du temps dans les climats tropicaux, inter tropicaux.
Ils sont en danger dans la mesure
où leurs milieux de vie sont en danger.
C'est à dire si la forêt dans laquelle
vit le phasme géant ou le papillon géant,
est en danger, évidemment,
le papillon va disparaître.
J'espère vraiment que nous continuerons
à avoir des insectes de grande taille,
mais avec le rythme actuel de destruction
de leur habitat dans le monde,
notamment dans les environnements tropicaux
où ces espèces sont répandues,
il est probable que beaucoup
d'entre elles vont disparaître,
tout comme les insectes géants.